para un nuevo capítulo de la eterna
crisis política de perú poco tiempo
después de ser destituido como ministro
del interior- por pedro castillo mariano
gonzález lanzó una serie de acusaciones
contra el mandatario tengo ninguna duda
del compromiso que el señor tiene con la
corrupción y no tengo ninguna duda que
esta salida abrupta tiene que ver con
obstruir la administración de justicia
el ex ministro también aseguró que fue
retirado el cargo que ocupó sólo durante
dos semanas por haber creado un grupo
especial de la policía nacional que se
encargaría de investigar a varios altos
funcionarios del gobierno luego de
conocer dicho testimonio la fiscalía del
país llamó a testificar a gonzález la
fiscal de la nación cita al ex ministro
del interior mariano gonzález para tomar
su declaración por los hechos relatados
que configurarían presuntos actos
delictivos una situación que profundiza
la inestabilidad del gobierno del
castillo que el martes nombró a willy
huerta como el séptimo funcionario en
cabeza de dicho ministerio pero el
inestable panorama político del país
latinoamericano no radica únicamente en
los constantes cambios en
a su medida de que castillo cumpla un
año en su cargo se enfrenta a un paro de
transportistas que bloquean las salidas
y entradas de varias ciudades del país
un descontento que se espera que llegue
a lima la próxima semana y que amenaza
con obstaculizar la continuidad de
castillo en su cargo la aprobación del
mandatario se encuentra en un 25 por
ciento